when AMD announced two different
graphics cards over at gamecon 2023 did
anyone else think the same thing which
is why does the 7700 XT exist I mean
it's 49 cheaper than the 7800 XT I just
don't understand why they'd release two
different gpus with such a similar price
point if we were talking like 149 versus
200 then yes that would make sense but
realistically if you're the sort of
person that does have deep enough
Pockets to be able to buy one of these
in the first place that extra fifty
dollars surely is attainable right I
mean don't get me wrong you would
absolutely be forgiven for wanting to
save yourself some money and either
putting that towards your gaming PC or
saving it for more of a rainy day but
I'm gonna jump the gun on a little bit
here and sort of express to you that
this card has four gigabytes less vram
than the 7800 XT the memory speed itself
is also slightly slower and performance
we're expecting to see actually quite a
big difference between this and the 7800
XT so this video is going to answer why
this thing exists why AMD is essentially
selling it now and obviously we will be
walking you through the performance
numbers thermals gameplay everything as
well as an unboxing and review of this
card itself the power color hellhound to
essentially help your buying decision
and if you are considering the 7700 XT
we'll probably be showing you why you
should be looking at something else
unless you're watching this a little bit
later down the line when pricing on this
thing has changed got that makes sense
wondering why my voice is all over the
place well me too but let's get this
thing unboxed and play some games right
after a short word from this video
sponsor cool says k70 Max is a game
changer for mechanical keyboards forget
about what color switch to go for
corsair's New mgx which is lets you
customize the actuation point of your
keyboard want a Supersoft touch for fast
reactions or do you prefer more Force to
stop mistakes ultimately the choice is
all down to you learn more about the k70
max today with the link down below right
then let's jump straight into it by
actually putting this under our overhead
take it out of the box and have a look
at what is on offer always excited to
test the new GPU that I haven't seen
before and here it is the power color
7700 XT hellhound I mean this is
actually a pretty nice feeling GPU it's
all metal I mean maybe that means it is
going to be slightly more expensive than
some of the competition I will stress as
well that when it comes to GPU pricing a
lot of the reviews are going to focus on
RRP but as we know pricing is quite
literally all over the place sometimes
they are quite a lot more expensive you
get a better SKU but then other times
you get ones that maybe aren't so
popular or smaller maybe only have two
fans use more Plastics and obviously the
prices of those do start to come down
quite a lot and this is definitely the
sort of GPU that I wouldn't want to
spend loads of money on because of
course it is so close to the 7800 XT in
terms of RRP anyway but in order for
this to make any sense at all you're
going to have to be looking at a more
value skew but assuming that you can get
this for a good price I think you will
be happy with the overall build quality
here I mean it's still two eight pins as
you'll find on the 7800 XT we've also
got this led switch on the top here
which I quite like because it makes it
easier to not line software you've got
this bios for overclock versus the
silent mode I don't really know anyone
that uses the silent mode let me know in
the comments below if you do use these
things most people just tune it in
software anyway this is very much a
triple fan design with as I say like a
full metal back plate on it and then
you've got this pass-through design here
as well so it's not the most overbuilt
solution in the world but for a graphics
card that's going to use around about
225 Watts or so it's probably about
right and I'm hoping it is going to be
very quiet but of course as we do have a
7800 XT here as well let's do a double
unboxing and here you can see what the
7800 XT reference design looks like and
I do not like this that's not to say you
should buy it but I mean look at it it's
it's offset it's not symmetrical It's
upsetting my eyes why have they done
this I mean it's quite clear that
they've almost kept this from the bigger
cards but then got rid of a fan and just
stuck it in the middle I I don't like
that I think it will look absolutely
fine if it's in your rig like this but
vertical GPU man I I do not like that at
all but yeah yeah this is definitely a
lot smaller than our power color card so
if you are going for an ITX rig
obviously this would make a whole lot
more sense but if you are going to go
for the quietest system possible then
I'd say grab something with three fans
if you can or at least get the best card
that you can within your means to
complete the Roundup we will grab the
Nvidia RTX 4070 this is much smaller
than all of these cards I mean it's not
crazy amounts of difference actually
between the AMD reference and nvidias
but that is definitely a fair bit
smaller but once you put the third party
card you can see that there's quite a
lot of difference there but yeah those
are the main physical differences
between these three cards let me know
which one is your favorite down in the
comment section below and ultimately are
you someone that would rather go for
like the reference or the Fe or do you
think going for something third party
has maybe a little bit more Flair well
let's move right on shall we and see if
we can get this in our rig as we screw
this in I should also say that the
minimum PSU recommendations of this is a
700 watt power supply but if you want my
personal opinion I think this is
probably a little bit of an overestimate
because they know a lot of people are
now buying crazy powerful I9 CPUs but
hey buying a 750 watt supply for this
does make sense anyway right let's turn
this on Moment of Truth
yes there we go I mean the hellhound is
always a card that's not really had any
RGB lighting it's just like blue but
personally speaking I always think this
looks quite nice I mean obviously if
you're going like all red build and no
you're going to want to go for something
else but I do like the default blue
lighting that you've got on here I think
it looks nice this does also operate
with the fans not spinning up unless
they actively need to which is nice so
if you're going to put it in like a
display case like this o11 Evo for
instance I think it is going to be a
very attractive graphics card right then
sorry everyone for this to be so jarring
but quite literally everything that
seems has gone wrong since I started
filming that last bit which for me was
four days ago but for you was mere
seconds first thing that happened the PC
decided to not like the windows install
and I couldn't fix it I had to reinstall
the lot then we ran out of time but then
much more importantly my illness got
worse and worse and worse and worse I
won't go into too many details but we
say it started here and ended a bit
lower
but fear not it's Monday now I'm feeling
better I've got access to Starfield
everything is looking up I've set up all
the cameras I start filming we go
through the Starfield performance
everything's looking good and my
microphone was off and that one wasn't
even plugged in as a backup so we're
going well but anyway you guys almost
certainly would rather hear about
Starfield and other game performance so
let's Jump Right In and we'll start with
Starfield this is the settings menu and
I'll be honest I don't like the fact
that you don't get an option of quality
presets when it comes to FSR it's not
actually a problem it just makes
benchmarking it for you and doing
comparisons that a little bit harder so
we currently got our render resolution
scale set to 85 and then the way we're
upscaling it is with fsr2 and then
everything else is actually set to ultra
across the board and I do want to make
it very clear that AMD has provided a
review code for this this is by no means
sponsored by AMD whatsoever but the
reason I'm mentioning this is because I
think this is an AMD optimized title so
I'm sure it's going to run very well on
AMD Hardware especially bear in mind you
can actually get a copy of Starfield
free it's not really free it's more
included if you do decide to buy one of
these gpus or one of their fancy ryzen
CPUs
please I haven't played Starfield yet
don't ruin the game it's literally gonna
be right at the start relax
and of course I would love to pretend
that this was all new to me as well
right but as I say the recording
previously failed so we're pretend shall
we that I haven't seen this before but
to be fair I'm not going to pretend that
the performance of this is subpar
because it's really not because what
you're seeing here is actually the game
running at 4K upscaled with FSR and I
think it is very very impressive that
you can get around about 50 frames a
second from what is a mid-tier
apparently 1440p GPU I mean this is what
we want to see from the Next Generation
right obviously this isn't going to
apply in every game this is literally
right at the start it's one scene this
does not mean that this is a 4K capable
GPU but especially at ultra settings 4K
I think it is very impressive that it is
able to run even the start of the game
at this level of frame rate especially
bear in mind over on the console side of
things you are capped at 30 frames a
second so bear that in mind as we
progress a little bit throughout the
game and to be fair if using a
controller and you're wanting to like
use freesync and stuff this is still
going to be a much better than console
ever experience but I won't lie it's not
the way I would want to play it's great
to have all of the visuals I mean it
looks absolutely fantastic down here but
I would wager that there are going to be
much more heavily intense scenes in this
game where you will want a little bit
more horsepower so turning down the
settings but more likely playing this at
1440p is going to be your best bet but I
hope you agree it is very interesting to
see this game running at such a high
frame rate on as I say what is
officially a mid-tier GPU though I don't
think spending 400 pounds on anything
really should be considered mid-tier so
let's go right ahead and turn this down
to 1440p which unfortunately does mean
running it in a window doesn't matter to
you does make it a bit sad for me then
fundamentally we will keep our FSR
rendering resolution at 85 and then you
can notice the difference and suddenly
we're gonna go much much higher frame
rate and this is the way you're going to
want to play the game around about 85 to
90 frames a second it gives you a lot
more wiggle room as well I mean I dare
say if you're in certain space scenes
you're going to get even higher than
this because it's not really that much
to render versus anything with a lot of
high density modeling and stuff that is
where your frame rate is going to start
to drop quite dramatically but at the
moment getting around about 92 frames a
second our GPU is being 100 utilized so
we're not anywhere near the bottleneck
or anything which is quite nice this is
actually a ryzen 7900 X so it's probably
high end it's not the absolute best of
the best you can go a little bit higher
but obviously for this GPU in this game
we're not seeing any bottlenecking which
is pretty darn tasty and how are we
doing for temperatures actually around
about 61 degrees with the hot spot being
83 so nothing really to worry about I'll
put the side panel on in just a second
but here's your noise test
which honestly is very very good you can
definitely hear it but it's a low tone
it's very consistent it's not annoying
but as soon as you put on that side
panel you're not really going to hear it
despite the fact that the temperatures
will of course increase slightly as
you're restricting the airflow a little
bit maybe not in this case because we've
got so many fans but before I forget
let's actually put our side panel on and
then everything you're seeing from now
on will be side panel on and then we can
move into our second game and this was
originally a PlayStation you guys know
by now it's one of my absolute favorites
this is maternal and I almost want to do
a bit of a ray tracing test here this is
currently running at 4K epic without any
Ray tracing at around about 50 frames a
second it's definitely playable with a
controller especially but I would
definitely recommend turning down some
of the settings more likely turning down
the resolution this actually isn't
running FSR or dlss or anything like
that I think my game for summary is even
synced to the cloud is still completely
bugged so do take this with a little bit
of pinch of salt because you can of
course use FSR but the test I want to do
do is Ray tracing let's see what we can
do I would say anything
60fps or above is playable and is how I
would choose to play the game so let's
see what we can do ray traced
Reflections low Ray traced Shadows low
is this gonna stay above 60 yes there
you go see we have some Ray tracing and
it works around about 70 FPS or so which
is pretty nice I imagine that this will
change when a lot of stuff is going on
screen quite a lot of time which is a
pretty frequent actually in return Also
let's see let's put this to the test
properly yeah there you go you can see
we're getting a little bit of Dipping
now around about 60 FPS on the low for
now I imagine there'll be sequences
where it gets even lower as well there
you go a little bit of stutter here and
there I do find that this is another one
of those titles that just does run
better on the Nvidia side of things but
whether that is because of the rate
tracing or not I mean not entirely sure
I mean yes okay things didn't go very
well there but you can still see there
was that horrible stutter and as someone
that has played this game all the way
through on an Nvidia card granted it was
a 4090 I didn't ever get that level of
stuff so that you can see on the frame
rate spiking here so that is a little
bit annoying and that is still going to
be a potential issue if you do want to
go for an AMD cards just be aware the
ray tracing isn't as good as it is on
the Nvidia side of things I mean to be
fair if it's on an AMD optimized title
The Ray tracing does tend to work a lot
better make of that what you will let's
move on though shall we to our
multiplier titles and we're going to
kick things off perfect timing there
with some Halo infinite this is running
at 4K Ultra no Ray tracing so once again
as we say every video 4K isn't realistic
for multiplayer but it does give you a
good comparison with The Next Generation
or definitely current generation
consoles and to be fair well the tone of
this video is very much that this card
should be a little bit cheaper you still
can't really argue with the overall
performance because I mean around about
60 FPS in a game like Halo at 4K
resolution is very very good and this
was out running any Dynamic scaling or
anything like that so it does show you
that the performance that this card does
have is very very good and if this card
ages like a lot of AMD graphics cards do
which is to actually get a fair bit more
performance over time with graphics
driver updates but much more importantly
this graphics card actually drops down
in price then I can see this
representing fantastic value for money
because fundamentally from what we've
seen so far this is a graphics card that
does actually have all of the
performance that you guys need but of
course as time goes on and games do get
more and more intense it's always nice
to have a little bit more in the bank
but how about we turn this down to 1440p
and change the quality preset to high to
I guess more replicate what people will
actually be using this graphics card for
when it comes to multiplayer and as you
can see the frame rate will increase
quite dramatically it's not not as much
as you see in some other games
interestingly enough but you're still
getting around about 100 110 FPS so this
is going to be super slick super smooth
especially on a monaster like this that
is 144 Hertz and overall I think this is
going to give you a fantastic way better
than console level experience but
ultimately it gives you that flexibility
of choosing the resolution and refresh
rate that you actively want it just
would be nice if we were to see some
active scaling Technologies and things
built into this game I mean you do
actually have the baked in minimum frame
rate that does work quite well but it'd
be nice to see FSR or something similar
properly embedded into the game although
we do have a little bit of negative news
I'm afraid and that is that the power
color GPU that we have here is starting
to make a little bit more noise than I
would like this is a bit of a torture
chamber in here it is very hot let's
check the thermostat it's actually 29
and a half degrees in here we've got all
the studio lights and things on and yeah
it's not going to be the most optimal
for thermals but we're currently
handling around about 62 degrees on the
GPU 84 on the hotspot so no real issue
there but the default fan profile I'd
say is a little bit too aggressive
because this sounds a bit
a bit loud if you ask me but yeah
there's plenty of tuning room I would
just make this run at like 75 degrees
personally and have lower noise but
obviously it's all entirely up to you
but of course I am well aware that there
are plenty of people that don't play
Halo they don't get on with it and
instead they play a little alternative
called Warzone and what you're seeing
here is running at 4K with FSR set to
Quality and we're running this at the
extreme preset and I've got to admit
while the performance of this cards when
it comes to Value might not necessarily
be the best but more on that a little
bit later I don't think too many people
are gonna be unimpressed with the
performance because you think this is 4K
and you are still able to get close to
100 frames a second I mean this is
something where AMD seems to really
Excel actually is in Call of Duty
Warzone because this is running
remarkably well it's very smooth it's
very nice to play and of course it's a
multiplayer title yes we know 1440p is
going to be the resolution most people
will be playing at but it's still very
cool to see this running flat out and it
doing so well AMD does a very very good
job in this department let's turn this
down to 1440p and as you can see the
frame rate has definitely increased I
mean it's quite easy maths we had about
100 before so we're getting probably
about a 45 to 50 performance increase on
average it's not doing much to help my
awareness unfortunately but it's still
showing you that yeah this is going to
be a very very good GPU if you do want
to play Call of Duty Warzone which is
nice but I think it's now time to get a
bit more technical I want to see the
hard numbers graphs Excel and
unfortunately I'm not the man to do it
and for the first time ever in PC
Centric history benchmarkers isn't
either let's hand you over to the one
the only bench Carl
whoa oh no hello everybody this is bench
Carl 100 not the same person as editor
Carl let's jump in let's start things
off with the 4K numbers and if we take a
closer look at the 7700 XT you can see
we're actually seeing a big increase in
performance compared to the last
generation 6700 XT and 6750 XT but we're
seeing very similar performance to that
of the RX 6800 this is both a good and
bad thing it's nice to see an
improvement but when the RX 6800 has 16
gigabytes of vram and is available for
about the same price it makes a 7700 XT
a very difficult car to recommend and on
average at 4K or about just 2 FPS faster
than the nearly three year old GPU and
for just 50 pounds or dollars extra you
can step up to the 7800 XT and enjoy a
nearly 20 performance bump at 4K in the
five games we tested taking a look at
cost per frame we can see there's a lot
of cards very close to each other but
the 499 pound RX 7800 XT blows them out
of the water usually the best cost per
frame cards are the absolute cheapest
the 7700xt meanwhile comes in at second
place but barely and if we did see a
price drop close to that of the 6750 XT
or 6700 xt's price then the 7700 XT
would be in absolute steal while the
7700 XT is one of the best value at 4K
the 12 gigabyte of vram is likely to
hamper it going forward at its
resolution which makes the RX 7800 XT or
even RX 6800 more appealing with their
16 gigabytes of vram moving on to 1440p
we can start to see which cards really
favor which games the AMD gpus perform
way better in Warzone 2 and Hogwarts
Legacy while the Nvidia cards tend to
perform better in Halo Forza and of
course in cyberpunk 2077. in the future
we'll hopefully add some more games to
try and even the pack out a bit but
that's a job for future car at 1440p
cyberpunk with Ray tracings is a good
performance increase compared to the
last generation of AMD gpus but it's
still miles off the Nvidia cards even
those without frame generation as far as
average performance goes the 7700 XT
looks to be be close to the RTX 4070 and
pulls a bit further ahead of the RX 6800
the 7800 XT takes a bigger lead over the
6800 XT so we think that is mostly down
to its big win in war zone 2 favoring
the newer AMD GPU here if you have a
look at Hogwarts Legacy Forza and
cyberpunk the 7800 XT is pretty much
neck and neck with the 6800 X2 which is
honestly a bit disappointing The only
positive thing for this 7800 XT versus
the 6800 XT is the price which we can
see helps to make it a much better value
product though if they just lowered the
price of this 6800 XT to 479 pounds it
would be more or less the same thing
this is a confusing sequel by Price
rather than performance moving on to
1080P and again we can see the Nvidia
cards top the leaderboard in Halo Forza
and cyberpunk and at 1080p this is where
the newest generation of AMD gpus makes
less sense as it's so much closer to the
last generation in Hogwarts Legacy we
seem to hit a CPU bottleneck which seems
to impact the Nvidia cards a lot more as
they all seem to be stuck around 150
into 120 FPS we did quite a bit of
retesting as we were kind of confused
here especially when the 2080 TI did so
well maybe a 14th gen Intel CPU or a
7800x 3D might help us spread these
cards out a bit more and alleviate that
bottleneck on average at 1080p we can
see the middle of the pack is a lot more
condensed as we're starting to see CPU
bottlenecking these cards will perform
extremely well at 1080p but their value
doesn't make a lot of sense as you'd
need to pair it with a top end CPU to
really extract the most out of them and
reduce that bottleneck we'll quickly
touch on power consumption but it's what
we would expect the AMD cards aren't
anywhere near as any GE efficient as the
Nvidia counterparts but providingly
offer much better value in the first
place and a much lower price it's a
little bit of an easier pill to swallow
overall we think the 7700 XT is a great
GPU it's just priced too high we'll
likely see the price come down like how
the 7900 XT launched at 899 and is now
about 750 so there's still hope for the
7700 XT to redeem itself if you truly
care about Ray tracing and value that
more than and raw rasterization
performance then the 47d is still your
only option anywhere near this price
point though that is going to cost you a
lot more closer to 580 pounds well then
ladies and gentlemen there we are the
7700 XT a graphics card I really wanted
to love because I thought it was going
to be the card of the generation but
unfortunately the main problem with it
is just that it's been overshadowed by
the significantly better 7800 XT for a
very similar price and it's annoyed me
in the past when reviewers have said oh
if only this card was like 20 30 50
cheaper it'd be really easy to recommend
But ultimately the 7700 XT is a perfect
example of that because when it's very
similar performance to a 6800 and
there's not really that much has changed
but more importantly you can get a lot
more performance for a mere forty fifty
dollars more which especially if you're
looking at like heavy aftermarket
versions of the cards might even be the
same price point it just makes it very
difficult to recommend which is actually
such a shame because because the
performance that you get this card is
fantastic and I think compared to most
of the Nvidia options as well this card
really does stand out in that regard and
it is definitely worth going but if you
can't get the 7800 XT that is now I
think the best card that you can buy as
far as I'm concerned that's the one I
would look at not obviously in terms of
outright best performance but when it
comes to Value when it comes to the
level of frame rate that you guys
actually need I think that is going to
be the best card for most people I mean
you've got more budget-friendly options
as well those are the ones that need to
come down but I think right in the
midpoint to give people the high-end
1440 the low end 4K performance we've
had a little bit of a gap for a while
and while I think more could have been
done with this 7800 XT obviously we want
more performance all the time I think
based on the current options of what
we've got I personally am very happy
with the 7800 XT and I know that this
card will come good a little bit later
in its life cycle once the price point
has reduced but that's my opinion let me
know your thoughts on this down in the
comment section below what do you like
about it what do you dislike to agree
with me that the pricing's a little bit
off or are you picking one of these up
day one I'd love to hear from you don't
forget to absolutely smash the like
button if you've enjoyed this get
yourself subscribed and of course if you
do want to check out current pricing on
anything featured in this rig including
the case the GPU maybe the ram you can
find that linked down below with our
Amazon affiliate links and while you're
down there why not bask in the glory of
corsair's k70 Max this epic keyboard
puts you in full control of the
activation Force for complete
customizability you can even assign two
different actions to each key press one
for a light tap another for a heavy the
board also packs per key RGB lighting
super smooth media controls and axon
processing for up to 8 000 Hertz of
polling rate get your game on today with
the link down below but thank you so
much for watching this video we'll catch
you in the next one
foreign
[Music]